three goals the last three games four
in the last five fory Panthers looking
for a two-on-one it's cousins with lundell
cousins Moves In for lundell in front and J
makes the save two-on one that the Panthers
enjoyed here here's Nick cousins streaking
down the left wing side he's got Mundell but
the pass was on his backand and you see the
saucer pass it bounced a little bit not a lot
of wood by lundell drops it off for Brandon
Montour back across kachuck has a chance J
the save and the cover patience he gives it
to Montour he has to circle around the net
back to kachuck and there's that shooting
Lane Bennett was trying to take the eyes away
from Jerry they went off of Bennett shot from
kachuck first shot on goal for the Panthers
in nearly seven minutes one Del fires it in
Carlson Under Pressure turned it over ecan Larson
shoots pass eight rebound wide Here Comes Crosby
coring skating right with him stride for stride
Crosby trying to get to the net the one-hander
save by Bovi with that left pad Puck def flexs
up towards the line kach Chuck settles it down
for hay trying to get the speed going to Center
here's mour over the line Montour great move in
a [__] drop pass K sh hit the post for shoots
deflected away post here's a good rush and you
see the Penguins backing right in monter leaves
it and Carter big Collision there lerin and went
down head to's back on his skates a turnover Eller
in front but Rosy the save behind [Applause] you
Bennett right off the bench cousins back
for Bennett in the slug Mika stopped by
jari there's big Nik Mika getting up in the
offense again for a great opportunity Smith
comes the other way with Malin Malin breaks it
in the back hand center Shot wide from ptin Puck
sitting on the back of that Panther net now
it's knocked off and Riley tries to flip it
in front and Smith Gil for Crosby in front barov
was there with him now Eric Carlson with the wrer
deflected save rovski that's a big stop on the
redirection in front never even crossed the line
[Applause] Here Comes Crosby bosi the save
Crosby on the rebound and we going to get a
penalty that's a hooking call and back for L Tang
he lost it marov tried to close on himang again
across one timer MOSI to save on pan Atman lson
shoots that goes wide and it carries out and gel
it's all alone he's got a breakaway gel in on bosi
to the back hand and Big Bob says no scoreless in
[Music]
Sunrise penguins with a quick out it's
a two-on one here comes Eller moving in
shooting B rosi again mour on the rebound very
insightful well here they are on the four check
but quickly again the Penguins get it out
and Malin moves against zlad Smith Salone
in front the pass the backhander score and
the Penguins cash it in for the first goal
of the game on a two-on-one and that's what we
were just talking about the head coach for the
Panthers and myself is when you're outman in
that neutral zone and we all know the former
Panther there it is up the wall Malin been so
many time stops and Spins and just centering
that Puck and it was timed perfectly onto
the Stick of Smith and all he had to do is
just bring it to the goal or to the backand open
up Sergey boski and slide it right between the
legs that's three odd man
rushes lar nice little move there to get in
for he he has eblad and the slot slap shot jar
with the glove and the whistle he doesn't see
the point in it because the same thing isn't
going to happen again see a lot of players
do it not Sam rard it's working for him oh
Conor got to the net had a chance there the
rovi made the save forgey checked battling
with Malin Malin unable to clear foring gives to
Reinhardt looking FAL ice shot here save by jari
here's Veri as the power play is over Rodriguez
now over to Veri shooting locked away another
shot Char the sa L and new score it's tipped
in by edman Lon and the Panthers have tied it
[Music] the Panthers needed a d man to come
in and finish off the play and Ean Larson did
exactly that did not score in the power play for
haggy One Shot Two Shots he's got lundell out in
front there's that loose Puck and Ean lson he
came in from that right point and just in the
nick of time to help nudge that puck over
the goal line what a run this season stenin
carries down the boards lenan takes over
now he's got a chance jar the save off his
mask Panthers one of the stingier teams in the
league in the third they've allowed a total of
20 goals in the final period the last half of
that second period Panthers did a lot better
Nikola with a Chance oh and jar got a piece of
it poring reads the play gets the steel the shot
deflected through the slot for hagy turns shoots
jar to save up high First Trade Bill Zito made
Panthers wi to draw here Rodriguez with a shot
save rebound score head to Len and in front gives
the Panthers their first lead of the [Music] night
oh that's a toe Tingler right there I said before
the Panthers had much improved in the faceof
dot in that second period and get that puck to
the net right off the draw r Rodriguez a shot up
high Andre and he just fumbles it can't track it
down lyster in and just knives his way right
through a couple of penguins of the coverage
and slaps of that puck right in the top part of
the net well two things that you felt like were
inevitable rosi settles it down for Nika
Crosby a steel in front he shoots it stck
oh Sergey bosski stayed with him and here
comes kachu the other way knocked off his
stick fory picks it up and a toe save
by jari there's the turnover and cros
you look at Sergey barros's concentration
and here's Montour with AER knock down in
front Bennett backhander went wide Bennett on
the loose Puck here's cousins in front save by
jari loose in the slot and then the cousins
come in went to the backhand to the forehand
so Conor for gensel gensel wrap around attempt
but rosi is there and gensel is up ended again
NE plad from his knees finds londell Panthers
have the odd man Rush it's loar and bursting in
on the back hand J to save the clearing attempt
deflected and state in the zone now bov gets it
out can Reinhard get there Reinhardt is in against
J shorthanded stopped Eric Carlson for Crosby
down to the goal line gensel Looks puts it in
front sa bosski it's bouncing around the slot
barov with the clear to the boards and barov
gets it to the line Penguins hold it in again
the power play is over six on five in the slot
Carlson stopped Reinhardt clears to Center two
onone with the empty net and barov big go
and the cat salted [Music] away incredible
shift by barov they kick it out of danger
penguins come back with another opportunity
Panthers get a hold of it Reinhardt over
to barov and he finishes it off with an
empty neck goal and with the win Sergey
boski moves in a 19th Place all alone in
the alltime list one behind former Panther
John Van beastbrook cats win it 3 to one